how's it going rest are you ready for a
ride
actually I need my glasses if we're
gonna do that welcome to knight rider
turbo it's a game made by salsa made
mega pixel and it's games are usually
pretty funny this one looks pretty
hilarious so let's fly let's add change
gear
okay maybe not change gear let's Oh
lights yes we need the lights on and the
wind show cuz it's not raining oh god
damn ah get away saying well yeah I
don't need you I don't need anybody's
help
yes kids so apparently my armor is
longer than my the [ __ ] universe
let's put on our that I know god damn it
yeah that's right baby
keep on crashing just a knifes a little
Sunday Drive no big deal
this is how most people in Sweden drive
I think if you're in UK oh my god oh my
steering wheel just left me come back
sorry well I lobby oh how do I kick in
the windshield come on
why do I have to drive so fast oh whoa
whoa oh no how is it a crack I haven't
even hit anything
oh that goddamn truck a citizen come
please SOS SOS oh now I know why his
name is sauce it all makes sense
how am I not being electrified seriously
don't drink and drive
ah [ __ ] don't drive without a steering
wheel either where's the Badger no bad
yeah what the [ __ ] it's there any way to
drive legal no no my blinkers is on stop
it car what's happening someone tell oh
I'm not even staring huh bye-bye
hi
brilliant Oh God Oh God oh that went
through me what the hell just gotta
follow the center it seems pretty Opie
well look at that
hacks pills hacks and try odd never my
ID ever mine it's kind of like surgeon
simulator meets meets drugs and raising
I don't even know watch yet
can't you see I'm driving [ __ ] this
is amazing how am I even on driving
right now I'm vertical
no one knows where I'm going no I know
wise I'm for having everyone just
wonders why is he driving naked how am I
still alive
holy [ __ ] that's my record
I literally just hold on I wouldn't be
needing this
now let's go baby oh I don't know how
this works gotta keep those windows
clean not [ __ ] there you go
that's right now that they're clean we
can keep going man I love driving that's
the best it's so relaxing so just going
a nice little ride if you know what I
mean oh hey babe
do you come here often what is this one
day oh gotta make sure people know that
I'm changing gear I mean that's real I
don't know what it's called in English
gear is the swanee the dildo part there
we go
wait let me pass
ah fisca all right let's give what
happens to the Cardo i just like go
through with them can't you see my
blinker is on everyone to see the naked
crazy guy driving around the road come
on get out of the way I need to go to
the hospital I have to deliver my baby
Gunther has to live god damn it
once his baby hits 88 miles per hour
shits about to go down in my new seats
and I don't want that I need a toilet
let me use my second power come here
tree what if they build this car with
duck shape seriously never got a baby
yeah oh no he was hiding did my will god
dammit professed brofist bro no go to my
only friend three it looks like it's in
the m3 I want you to know hey I cheated
on your girlfriend
hi I'm sorry don't judge me Trey god
damn it get out of here yeah that's
right I don't need no tree oh this game
is so ridiculous seriously it's so hard
yo no don't drive in yo lebra's it's
dangerous don't do anything in yellow
actually yeah I think about it I can
break the shield why would I do with a
high five windshield high five
alright so that was knight rider turbo I
mean I played some realistic games in my
days but I think this is probably one of
the most realistic ones it's a fun game
regardless I hit 6.4 I think so I'll
leave a link in the description if you
want everyone to check it out and see if
you can beat my high score other than
that I hope you guys enjoyed watching
leave a like if you did I really
appreciate it
I'm currently moving so I'm sorry if
these episodes are short or less videos
hit subscribe convert day and I see
person next one say awesome love you
also I just realized while I'm shooting
this that Paul Walker died a few days
ago in a car accident
it's a shame stuff like that happens be
be safe on the roads press